turn and
then just getting dep in my feet
okay as I do this I have to always be
thinking of that CR check stop doing
your like
that you are immediately thinking how to
get on the outside and checking at the
elbow okay you have to
get I don't know what that's
about well second they touch
on okay then the
drill keep everything locked locked
locked lock I'll show you what I'm
seeing I'm seeing no me I'm seeing this
crazy ass hand workk and then as you
guys are turning you're and moving
there's a lot of wiggling in
here okay
no I don't want to
Boom turn it's all locked locked it
stays locked locked lock
okay so as I'm stepping into a deeper
stance the rear foot is no more open
than 45° angle don't turn this to 90 or
Worse the other way it's now not
oriented into the fight 45° angle and
then don't let the arch cave
in push the arch up energy runs down the
back outside of the
leg so you activate the
glute
move turn lock 45°
angle activate the back outside of the
GL don't let the arch cave in boom okay
let's go so uh can you go forward can
you go
forward it's not a free all I I decide
how much she moves okay she can only
feel what I'm letting
okay so if you this is what I'm talking
about and her arm you guys's arm is here
her arm is here
okay all right next thing when I step
into this deeper stance and I don't care
if you go both feet it doesn't matter
we're just working
on
architecture okay but when I do go into
it the hips are with the feet boom boom
got it
no you see this you're going to make the
inside cave so this hi is forward okay
and I'm just going to keep lowering
that okay so I do the first part
Mo
move keep everything
locked move 45° angle on the back
foot lead hip is becoming the lead
HP keep it locked
okay a very common mistake in all of you
is because you don't have mid foot
weight so you start to move the drill
I'm doing the drill right and you go you
start going like that so your angle this
way you see so we have this is this U is
incorrect that what you want to call
that whatever that is and then this one
you see leing in
alignment with that leg okay leing in
alignment with that leg don't go like
that you're fing okay come
on okay uh we'll be on this line you
guys see East West line okay I am going
inep here with my ten
con let describe that I'm about a foot
south of that East West line you see
that okay now I do that
movement what do you what's happening
I'm going forward right you see that and
if I try to go
back now what's
happening my weight's on my heels too
see what can you do
so
much it kind of matters where you put
your
foot you guys put it wherever you want
and then you just wing it you have to
put your foot so that you can get this
alignment if it's too far out too far
close too far forward too far back it
does different things which is why I'm
letting you move your feet either one
okay is drill so if you go there when
it's time to do the drill I told you get
in position however you want okay
however you
want okay you got it you guys got it
don't leave it there if it's not if it's
inhibiting you from doing the right form
and you're making one of those three
mistakes okay
this time I won't let you move your back
foot where you want you are going to put
it where it needs to go and it is going
to push into that St you see
that one I put it right behind the other
foot so it can push into
that
one two
drop one don't unlock anything 45°
angle drives me into that stance I have
not lifted or lowered my arm I have not
lifted or lowered my
torso one two body block push
okay let's
try don't don't
disconnect so your your foot is too far
out got it so your weight is going to go
to your heels so you're compensating by
leaning forward then he nudges you then
you fall forward
okay
out you bent your
waist your foot is caving and it's not
at a 45° angle
forward let me try it again stay CL I
know I
here and I'm I'm using some sort of
engine to to show that for line you got
it okay uh one
is one is my arm goes up and
down another one is my torso goes up and
you see that those all require you to
move something that requires your levers
to be capable of moving the resistance
that means you need to be strong enough
to do it okay we're going to do a third
one I don't lift anything because I
don't lower anything I'm just here and I
move my whole body my whole body
moves can you see that
so I don't want to leave my hand up I
have to be strong have to do that I
don't want to go like this yeah we some
of us can get very strong like that
but it's still
strength okay I'm just
here and I use my
body you see that okay let's
go so this foot is too far back in order
to push her forward because in terms of
moving forward you're near the end of
your capacity so this foot's not going
to push you and what you're going to do
instead is fall into the stance you
understand okay secondly this foot is
too far south for the t con so the hips
are square so when you do that step like
that you're probably going to keep
Square hips so now you're going to have
to use strength one of
them okay this foot goes behind the
other foot at the 45°
angle got it and you're at the 45° angle
so this hip has to follow this foot
that's not
okay this is
here and this glute drives you
forward okay let's
go okay get up get up let go let go
where's my
hand's your
hand you feel the technique kind of like
stall because this was too weak yes okay
with uh
what what do I do all right how do I do
it so pay
attention my line of gravity identified
okay now I can start
to go
forward see that so what am I doing when
I do
that I am kind of leaving the line of
gravity in this kind of lifted
suspension when I
step that's not it okay what I'm doing
is immed
pushing the line of gravity so option A
I step and I drop option b pushing
forward
okay so I'm here and I'm going to step
and
drop now I want this
glute to push me
forward it's like this stay still
I'm going
to step and
drop I'm going to push me
forward see that difference okay so you
know you want to get down but you're
here and that's
weak drive yourself forward okay try
okay let's go